welcome to Tech news briefing it's
Thursday May 18th I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
calls to ban Tick Tock in the U.S are
growing louder from lawmakers cyber
Security Experts and parents many of
these concerns center around whether
tick tock's Chinese owner bite dance
could be forced to share information on
users with a government in Beijing
something Tick Tock has said it would
never do but our family and Tech
columnist Julie jargon has been writing
about an issue with Tick Tock that made
me more worrisome to parents tick tock's
algorithm and the dark content it can
lead users to tick tock says it has a
team of people moderating content and
removes posts that violate its Community
guidelines so Julie why did you decide
to write about this issue well like you
said there are all these calls to ban
tick tock on the grounds that users data
could wind up in the wrong hands and
while that may be a valid concern I
think for parents the real issue is what
their kids are seeing on Tick Tock some
of my colleagues conducted a big
investigation two years ago which found
that tick tock's algorithm steers
viewers to dangerous content pretty
quickly and I wanted to see if that's
changed and what did you find I found a
study conducted by the center for
countering digital hate
that showed that the accounts belonging
to fictitious 13 year olds were very
quickly inundated with videos about
eating disorders self-harm and suicide
The Wall Street Journal as you mentioned
did this investigation in 2021 and found
tick tock's dears viewers to dangerous
content we actually did a series on this
show called The Tick Tock spiral that
examined this
has anything changed on Tick Tock since
then well according to the study that
the center for counting digital hate
conducted a few months ago teens were
still seeing a lot of very harmful
content about self-harm suicide and
eating disorders and they shared all of
their research with me because I wanted
to see had anything changed since they
released the findings of their study
and some of the videos that they flagged
in their study have been taken down
however I looked at all of the accounts
from which those problematic videos came
and most of those accounts are still up
on Tick Tock and contain other similar
videos about self-harm suicide and
disordered eating
what is Tick Tock said about this Tick
Tock says that they have more than 40
000 safety professionals who write
Community guidelines and moderate
content and that they do remove any
posts that are considered to be in
violation of those Community guidelines
that include specific references to
suicide self-harm and eating disorders
they said that they do not allow content
that glorifies or promotes those things
however they do allow content that is
considered to be educational or to show
people who are in recovery from
self-harm and eating disorders you yeah
that gets into this really interesting
question of these gray areas because
some users might be posting about their
experience they might want to share
their recovery Journey on Tick Tock but
for other people watching maybe
particularly for young people that could
end up being harmful how does tick tock
deal with that yeah I think tick tock's
kind of having a hard time with that
they mentioned and they've cited experts
who say that to not include those kinds
of videos could be detrimental that they
don't want to stifle those types of
videos because people who are watching
might need an outlet and want to find
other people who have recovered from
some of these things but it's a
difficult position to be in because it's
hard I think for some people to
determine what constitutes recovery
content or something that's educational
versus what could be harmful there's no
black and white line Julie two-thirds of
U.S teens use tick tock according to the
Pew Research Center how big a deal is it
for them to see this there's been a fair
amount of research by now that has shown
that this can have a negative influence
on teens if they're watching continuous
videos of Despair and other problematic
content that it can have an impact on
their own mental well-being it
normalizes you know some of these issues
and can make teens feel like these
things are maybe more common than they
are if you're not seeing sort of a
balance of content with no positivity to
kind of balance it out it can change the
world view of a young person to think
that everything is hopeless and sad the
data that's out right now about the
youth Mental Health crisis shows that a
sizable percentage of teens say they
feel hopeless
are there ways to keep kids and teens
safe if they're on tick tock there are
some things that teens could do and that
parents can help them do one thing is
parents can set up their own Tick Tock
account and use the app's family pairing
feature that allows parents to restrict
age inappropriate content and limit the
amount of time teens spend on the app
there are also ways within the app that
people can filter out videos that
contain words or hashtags they don't
want to see
however one of the problems with you
know the content like this slipping
through is that you know Tick Tock has
filters for certain words you can't
search the word suicide and get to
anything but people use sound alike
words they misspell words or they write
the word attempt meaning attempt suicide
and that can evade tick tock's content
filters so you still have to be careful
if you see a video that you don't want
to see again or videos like it you can
tap not interested and a newer feature
that could be helpful is teens can
refresh their feed altogether I've
talked to teens in the past who have
told me that they're for you Pages
became filled with so much problematic
content that they just closed out their
accounts and at some point decided to
start over fresh so now teens don't have
to do that but you know then they have
to still be vigilant about the new
content they're seeing and they watch it
or Linger on or like a particular type
of content they're going to see more of
it so Tick Tock said that it's
continually adjusting its algorithm to
avoid repeatedly recommending viewers a
narrow range of content but it's hard to
know how well that's working
all right that's our family and Tech
columnist Julie jargon thanks for
bringing us this story Julie thank you
for having me
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]